رفعت شبكه الجزيره العالميه قضيه اغتيال
جميله شيرين ابو عقله من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في لاهاي
وقالت الشبكه في بيان ان هذه الخطوه تاتي
بعد اجراء فريقها القانوني تحقيقا كشف عن
ادله جديده تظهر بوضوح شيرين وزملائها
تعرضوا لاطلاق نار مباشر من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وانا ادعاء السلطات
الاسرائيليه بانها قتلت او قتلت شيرين خطا
خلال تبادل اطلاق النار ادعاء لا اساس له
واضافت الشبكه ان الملف المرفوعه للمحكمه
الجنائيه يؤكد انه لم يكون هناك الشباك في
المنطقه التي كانت فيها شيرين
واكدت ان هذا القتل العمد كان جزءا من
حمله اوسع للسيدات في الجزيره واسكاتها
وخلال المؤتمر الصحفي في لهاي اعرب
ديكسون محامي شبكه الجزيره على بلده في
احراز تقدم في قضيه شيرين خلال الاشهر
المقبله مؤكدا ان المحكمه الجنائيه لديها
صلاحيه الكامله للنظر في قضيه شيرين
ملف الادله الكامل الى المدعي العام في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ونظرا الى ان
هناك ملفا وقضيه مرتبطه بفلسطين نطالب
بالنظر في القضيه باسرع وقت ممكن في
القضيه التي رفعناها نشير الى ان المدعيه
العام لديه ادله كامله جمعناها خلال
الاشهر الماضيه من خلال شهود عيان
وفيديوهات جديده
على المحكمه الجنائيه تحديد الافراد
الضالعين بشكل مباشر في قتل شيرين
والمحكمه الجنائيه لها صلاحيه كامله للنظر
في هذه القضيه ليس فقط لمحاسبه المسؤولين
المباشرين بل ايضا من تقاعسو عن منع
حدوثها
ومن جانبها قالت ابنته شقيق شيرين ابو
عقله لينا ابو عقله قالت نعي اسرائيل
لديها تاريخ في استهداف الصحفيين بهدف
اسكاتهم عن قول الحق وهي دائما تفلت من
العقاب وتخلقوا ثقافه افلاط من العقاب
مشيره ثقافه الافلات من العقاب واشرت الى
ان الوقت قد حان لمحاسبتها
عندما
الاسره الدوليه
هو الشخص الذي اطلق الرصاصه القاتله ومن
هو المعني في سلسله القياده
عبد الله الشامي عبد الله التابعه فصوله
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي الذي يعتقل مازال
متواصلا الى حد الان ما الذي يسوقفك في
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي وما هي ابرز المواقف
التي تم التعبير عنها
نعم بالطبع بجانب الفريق القانوني وعائله
شيرين كان هناك ايضا تواجد لكل من المدير
التنفيذي لمنظمه الصحفيون بلا حدود كذلك
المدير عن المعهد الدولي للصحافه كانت
هناك مواقف قويه في هذا السياق خصوصا فيما
يتعلق بربما اخر التطورات التي كان من
ضمنها همم حديث المسؤوليه الاسرائيليين عن
انه لن يتم التعاون مع اي جهه او ولن يكون
هناك اصلا يعني تقديم لاي من الجنود الى
التحقيق كان هناك رد في هذا السياق حول
مساله ان التحقيق لم يفتح في الاصل ببناء
على مدى التفاعل الاسرائيلي وانما هو فتح
من قبل همم يعني همم سواء هذه الفريق
القانوني او من قبل شبكه الجزيره لاجل ان
يكون هناك السعي الى الحقيقه الحقيقه في
مقتل 20 ابو عقله وانه ليس بالضروره ان اي
رد من قبل سلطات الاسرائيليه هذا الرد همم
الاول على هذا الحدث اليوم تقديم الملف
بشكل كامل ورسمي ملف التحقيق في مقتل
شريان الذي تم منذ سته اشهر الى المحكمه
الى مكتب المدعي العام المدعي العام الذي
اعلن بالامس خلال الجلسه العامه للجنائيه
الدوليه الى انه سيزور الاراضي الفلسطينيه
التي فتح فيها تحقيق العام الماضي بشكل
رسمي سيزورها خلال همم الايام الاولى من
العام المقبل وان هناك ضمن سيجري لهذا
الملف الى همم او ملف اغتيال شيرين ابو
عقله الى هذا الملف الاكبر بالطبع ايضا
الفريق القانوني اليوم تحدث عن ان رغم عدم
توقيع اسرائيل على الميثاق المؤسس للمحكمه
الجنيه الدوليه الذي يعرف ميثاق روما الا
ان وقوع الجريمه على اراضي فلسطينيه اي في
جنين التي همم بدورها جزء من همم يعني
السلطه الفلسطينيه التي وقعت على على
ميثاق المحكمه بالتالي هذا لا يعني انه لا
يمكن محاسبه المسؤولين عن هذه الجريمه
الملف ايضا لا يتعلق فقط بمن نفذ هذه
الجريمه الجندي الذي اطلق النار وانما
ايضا الترابيه اي وصولا لا اعلى القياده
العسكريه وكذلك السياسيه المسؤوله عن هذا
الفعل كذلك الفريق القانوني تحدث عن انه
سيسعى الى عقد اجتماع رسمي مع المدعي
العام قبل
زيارته للاراضي الفلسطينيه للحديث اكثر
حول هذا الملف وانه سيواصل على كل
المستويات القانونيه والدبلوماسيه ايضا
لاستعي الى ان يكون هناك كشف عن من ارتكاب
الجريمه ليس فقط مجرد شكرا تقديمهم او
معرفه اسماءهم وانما ايضا تقديمهم الى
المحاكمه اشكرك يا عبد الله الشامي مراسله
جزيره همم من